609 let's balance ourselves out here
with a major off-road racing event back
here in las vegas the mid-400 off-road
race is this weekend bianca holmen
joining us live downtown where those
festivities start today bianca what are
you driving what are you driving
you know this bronco out here is looking
pretty nice take a look at this beauty
off road in the desert hundreds of
people are going to be out here this
weekend taking on this race this weekend
so it's all open to the public there's a
festival happening right here on
friedmond street
before the race so the mid-400 has a
long history here in las vegas it's
known as the great american desert race
the race started in 1968 in downtown las
vegas and took place ever since in the
desert outside gene min 400 is the
oldest and most prestigious off-road
race in the country and it draws out
some big names with the need for speed
400 is a part of the dna of las vegas
history you know we've had famous
celebrities from james gardner to steve
mcqueen come and race it and this year
is no different this year we have haley
deegan nascar star racing with us
donald cowboy cerrone ufc fighter dan
henderson ufc hall of famer and ryan
bader who is the current bellator
heavyweight champion all racing with us
some big names there so last year the
race was in december and matt martelly
says that it's great to be back at the
traditional time of year and this season
so coming up next in the next half i'm
going to share more about what people
can expect with this year's race back to
you guys in the studio